Jasin bicycles from home to the train
station at an average speed of 10 miles
per hour
then he boarded a train and traveled
into the city at an average speed of 50
miles per hour the entire distance was
30 miles the entire trip took 1 hour how
many miles did Jason travel by train so
let's write that down as a variable so
let's say distance and we'll write a
little small T right here a little
subscript T this is the distance by
train so train train distance train
distance right there and let's have a D
with a little bit of a little B right
there that is the bike distance that is
the bike distance now they give us one
piece of information that the total
distance the entire distance was 30
miles so that means that the distance by
train plus the distance by bike is 30
miles so I could write that right here
the distance by train plus the distance
by bike is equal to 30 miles that's what
that constraint tells us now the next
one they tell us that the entire trip
took one hour so the time by train plus
the time by bike took one hour and you
might behave G that's going to introduce
two new variables but let's take a
little bit about whether we can express
the time by train and the time by bike
in terms of these two variables so just
as a bit of review and I think this is
review you're probably familiar with
distance is equal to rate times time or
if you divide both sides of this
equation by rate you get time is equal
to distance divided by rate time is
equal to distance divided by rate so
let's think about the situation for each
of these guys what is the time by train
I'll write it like this the time by
train is going to be equal to the
distance by train divided by the rate
that the train was going at and they
gave us that information they told us
that the the train traveled into the
city at an average speed of 50 miles per
hour that is the rate of the Train so
the time traveled the time of the train
was the distance of the Train divided by
50 same exact argument
the time of the bicycle the time
traveled on the bicycle will be the
distance traveled on the bicycle divided
by the speed of the bicycle and they
give us the speed right there ten miles
per hour and everything in this problem
we're assuming is going to be neither
miles or hours so there's not any major
unit conversion so that's there right
there so the second statement is that
the entire trip took one hour so the
time by train plus the time by bicycle
is going to be one hour actually let me
do that in a different color the tire
trip took one hour so this time plus
this time is one hour and I'm going to
write it in terms of the distances so I
only have two unknowns so the time by
train is the distance by train divided
by 50 plus the time by bicycle is the
distance by bicycle divided by 10 and
then that is equal to one hour that's
what this statement right here is
telling us although we have to use that
information and that information to
divide by the ten and to divide by the
50 now we have two equations of two
unknowns and our whole goal the whole
purpose of this problem they want to
know how many miles did Jason travel by
train so we want to figure out we want
to figure out that variable or we want
to figure out that variable now the
easiest way to do this is if we can just
eliminate the distance by bicycle and
then solve for the distance by train
then we're done we would have solved the
problem now the easiest way I can think
of doing that is this one is pretty
simple already let me just rewrite it to
the right here so the distance by train
plus the distance by bicycle is equal to
30 and I want to cancel out the distance
by bicycle so if I could make this into
just a negative distance by bicycle then
I'm all set and if I add the two
equations they'll cancel out so the
easiest way to just make this a negative
distance by bicycle is multiply both
sides of this equation by negative 10
multiply both sides of this equation by
negative 10 because you multiply
negative 10 times this the 10s cancel
out this just becomes a negative
distance by bicycle so let's write it
over here negative 10 times the distance
by train over 50 10 divided by 50 is 1/5
so it's negative 1/5 all right this way
negative 1/5 distance by train
and the negative ten times this
expression right here the 10s cancel out
is just negative distance by bicycle is
equal to four four at that parenthesis
is equal to negative 10 is then the
whole point here is so that this becomes
the negative version of that so when I
add these two equations they'll cancel
out so let's do that let's add these two
equations so if you add the left-hand
side these guys cancel out you have a 1
DT minus 1/5 DT 1 DT you can view as 5/5
DT so 5/5 minus 1/5 you have 4/5
distance by train is equal to 30 plus
negative 10 or is equal to 20 now to
solve for distance by train we can just
multiply both sides of this expression
both sides of this equation by the
inverse of 4/5 so we'll multiply both
sides by 5 over 4 the whole point of
that is that the this cancels out and we
are left with we are left with the
distance by train is equal to 20 times
5/4 that's the same thing as 20 over 1
times 5/4 20 divided by 4 is 5 4 divided
by 4 is 1 so it's just 5 times 5 so the
distance traveled by train is 25 miles
and we're done and we could go back if
we wanted to figure out any of the times
or the distance by bicycle actually it's
very easy the distance by train is 25
distance by bicycle has to be 5 if
they're gonna add up to be 30 miles